so let me ask you both at the same time
what is the state of your relationship
I think that we're talking a lot more
I think our relationship is growing I
mean I think we're seeing where this is
going
she won't even look at it okay you are
not exclusive right now
well I mean you know Natalie is still
married as well so
would you consider Natalie your
girlfriend
[Laughter]
um no title
yeah I mean I don't think that we've had
that conversation or I've officially
she's moving across the country to be
closer to you and she's not even your
girl it's not it's not just to be closer
to me she's not just it's not just for
that but like come on well honestly
wanted to take away from you she is
basically an edge of being a girlfriend
right right right is a politician he's a
politician you're a dirty politician
I'm doing it all committed yeah you
don't want to admit that she's your
girlfriend well what I want to know is
why won't Natalie even look at you why
won't you even look at him like are
y'all in a fight right now or you're
definitely not in a fight well y'all are
being very cool yeah
look I I mean I get it but there's still
a lot of things that Natalie needs to
figure out it's not just my decision
here what does he need to figure out we
just need some answers well I mean
can you please be specific at least I
know yeah well I mean it's not just a
crack at it I think you you want her to
figure out if she's done with Mike or
not
absolutely
I will never
divorce for a guy who is not going to be
there for me and I don't give a purchase
information I didn't and I would not ask
you to get a divorce I'm not that's not
what I'm but they're asking for you have
to make your own decisions so are you
staying married
it's my personal choice
I mean this is clear for me I'm not his
girlfriend so why would I have to
divorce Michael why do I have to put
myself in situation where I feel
uncomfortable and secure why for who who
is there for me empty space
no I'm not doing it
[Music]
thank you